Euh j'espère que éventuel
si interprété
comme euh et euh quelque part je sais
pas s'il va me me féliciter ou pas
de ce qui me semble être formidable
formidable des façons des façons
d'éviter
de des problèmes fondamentaux d'avance.
Merci madame la présidente. Monsieur le
rapporteur, euh j'espère que un éventuel
cynisme dans mes propos ne sera pas
interprété comme la théorise.
Euh et euh quelque part je sais pas s'il
doit me me féliciter ou pas de de
participer de ce qui me semble être
formidable formidable façon d'éviter
d'éviter de discuter des problèmes des
problèmes fondamentaux concernant les
bons lieux les bécoes publiques l'école
publique les pratiques de virtuel de
surveillance tant internet parfait
par lorsque l'on évoque la question la
questionalisme et la
radicalisation la radicalisation la
radicalisation je la radicalisation
messieur bonjour nous vous
intervievousons aujourd'hui pour un une
chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle Serview on
aurait aimé avoir votre avis sur les les
derniers les dernières gesticulations de
nos gouvernants concernant la
surveillance commencer avec Jérémy
Zimmerman. Jérémy Zimmerman. Bonjour.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ?
Qu'est-ce que je peux dire ? Beaucoup de
choses. Euh, on est dans une période un
petit peu trouble, une espèce de
d'accélération de de la spirale
sécuritaire que l'on vit depuis le 11
septembre 2001. Euh un empilement de
mesures législatives, d'une espèce de
1000 feuilles politiques et législative
qui nous qui nous pousse toujours plus
loin dans la surveillance de masse. Euh
et dans ce qui ressemble de plus en
plus, c'est une sorte de dérive
autoritaire. des gouvernements
occidentaux, une forme de réponse à la
terreur par la terreur qui en quelque
sorte fait le jeu des terroristes.
On l'a vu en France au cours de ces 12
derniers mois, il y a eu le vote de la
loi de programmation militaire, la LPM,
qui autorise une surveillance de masse
par des entités administratives pour des
types de données et des sources
particulièrement floues dans la loi et
pour des types de de crimes, pour des
types d'enquêtes là aussi
particulièrement vaste suivi de très
près euh de la loi antiterroriste votée
en novembre 2014.
euh qui outre restriction de liberté de
mouvement instaure cette nouvelle
catégorie de citoyens qui sont des
suspectés futur terroristes pour
lesquels la police a à peu près tous les
droits de restreindre leur liberté de
mouvement, de les surveiller et cetera.
Et laquelle loi euh antiterro ajoute
cette à cette notion enfin sort je crois
du droit de la presse cette notion
d'apologie du terrorisme pour en faire
un délit. et donne euh au pouvoir
public, à l'exécutif, donc au ministère
de l'intérieur, la possibilité de
censurer des site internet qui feraiit
l'apologie du terrorisme. Alors le le 8
janvier, au lendemain du massacre de de
Charlie Hebbdo, le gouvernement français
envoyait à Bruxelles son projet de
décret d'application de l'alopsie et de
la loi terro concernant le la censure.
C'était du réchauffé. Donc bon, la
lopsie, ça fait des années qu'elle avait
été votée en 2010 je crois. Euh le
gouvernement euh à l'époque était celui
de François Fillon et les députés
socialistes étaient vents debout contre
la censure. On déposé un recours au
Conseil constitutionnel très fourni euh
qui avait été rejeté mais était
complètement opposé à cette censure
qu'ils ont voté des demains lorsqu'il
s'agissait de l'apologie du terrorisme.
Donc il s'agissait du même décret, c'est
assez intéressant, un même décret pour
une loi votée sous Sarkozy et pour une
loi votée sous Hollande qui disait
exactement la même chose et qui a été
transmise à Bruxelles le lendemain des
attaques.
Le le décret a été depuis publié et on
attend les les détails d'implémentation.
Et ce que l'on a donc depuis depuis 2
jours, depuis la la publication de ce
décret, c'est aujourd'hui en France une
censure administrative d'Internet pour
les sites euh pédopornographiques, pour
les sites faisant l'apologie du
terrorisme. Euh c'est évident que cette
liste de motifs va s'élargir au cours du
temps. On attend de voir les Charlot du
disque et du film obtenir eux aussi que
le ministère de machin euh demande à ce
qu'on enlève des sites de l'internet.
Euh, on attend de voir ce qui va se
passer. On l'a vu avec les les récentes
arrestations et mises en examen pour
apologie du terrorisme que quand un ados
republie une caricature qui reprend une
caricature de Charlie Hebdo qui disait
le le Coran c'est de la merde, ça
n'arrête pas les balles. Pour dire
Charlie c'est de la merde, ça n'arrête
pas de les balles dans une mise en abîme
assez assez splendide. Euh ce qui
pourrait être considéré comme de
l'humour peut-être pas forcément drôle
par certains que Boom s'est qualifié
d'apologie du terrorisme. Euh le truc de
de Dieu donné qui a obtenu sa campagne
de pub internationale en disant je me
sens Charlie Koulibali euh apologie du
terrorisme et cetera. Si c'est ce même
type de propos qui sont considérés comme
apologie du terrorisme par le ministère
de l'intérieur qui va automatiquement
envoyer un message au fournisseurs
d'accès pour leur demander de de
d'empêcher d'accéder à certains. C'est
une privatisation de la justice. Là,
c'est une administratisation, une
exécutivisation. C'est un contournement
de la justice, ça c'est sûr. Parce que
c'est plus de la justice en dans en ce
sens qu'il y a pas de juge. Est-ce que
c'est un airat ? Est-ce que c'est un
airat de la stasie, c'est-à-dire un
renforcement de la police administrative
à un tel point qu'on est capable de
bypasser le juge ? Écoute, j'ai du mal
avec les analogies historiques comme ça
pour dire est-ce que c'est pire ou mieux
que la Stasi, plus gentil ou plus
méchant que les nazis, pire ou moins que
le sent
euh
une chose est sûre, c'est que c'est un
renforcement des pouvoirs de l'exécutif
au dépend du judiciaire qui dans une
démocratie est le gardien des libertés
fondamentales, que c'est une dérive
sécuritaire
Et surtout, c'est quelque chose qui me
dérange au plus haut point dans ma ce
qui me reste de fibre républicaine, si
j'ose dire, c'est que c'est une tendance
qui touche exactement de la même façon
la droite et la gauche. 1h3 après les le
massacre de de Charlie Hebdo, il y avait
un communiqué de l'UMP pour dire que
l'UMP soutiendrait le gouvernement dans
tout ce qu'il ferait en matière de
sécurité. Et lorsque la loi Terro a été
votée, on a vu les gens à la droite de
la droite de la question. Attends, il y
avait Thierry Marianni et Jacques Miard
qui applaudissaient le gouvernement pour
sa loi terroriste. Donc quand on en voit
d'autres de l'autre côté qui sont en
train d'encaisser des points en disant
UMPS tous les mêmes et qu'on voit UMP et
PS voter les les mêmes les les mêmes
saletés, euh quelque chose qui me fait
très mal. On prend plus le temps de
réfléchir.
Mais c'est normal, il y a une telle
émotion face à Charlie Hebdo que bah
forcément les politiques se sentent
obligés de faire quelque chose, de
communiquer leur action et c'est une
vieille méthode qui avait qui a connu
son heure de gloire du temps de SarkoZi.
C'est un fait d'hiver, une loi. Et ben
là, ça continue dans le même sens. Il y
a le fait d'hiver euh Charlie Hebdo, il
faut montrer qu'on est aux commandes, il
faut montrer qu'on fait quelque chose et
si tu veux euh c'est une façon de
montrer Alors, on va faire un début de
présentation. Alors, Tristan exmodila,
euh vous avez fait une thèse sur la
surveillance. Vous êtes en train de
faire une thèse ? J'ai J'écris j'écris
un livre sur sur la surveillance. Tout à
fait. parce que c'est c'est un sujet qui
me préoccupe énormément aujourd'hui, pas
simplement dans le cadre qu'on discute
aujourd'hui, mais euh ça fait des années
que ça commence avec tout ce qui est
business model autour du profilage des
internautes et cetera. Donc, plus
largement, on voit la confluence des
intérêts
économiques et la surveillance par les
États et les services secrets.
Travailler ensemble. Par exemple, les
révélations Snowden ont été très très
intéressantes de ce point de vue-là. et
et là ben voilà, je viens de quitter mon
job, j'ai du temps pour écrire un livre
et je me précipite, je prends ce temps
pour écrire ce livre parce que il y a il
y a beaucoup de choses à expliquer pour
faire comprendre aux gens que la
surveillance c'est quels sont les
risques quels sont les risques si comme
vous appelez la pleb les gens ne
comprennent pas le le la problématique
quels sont les risques ? Ah ben il y a
il y a il y a il y a des il y a des tas
de risques. Euh premièrement euh le fait
que quand on est euh quand on on se sait
surveiller en permanence en fait on
s'autocensure et on s'habitue à ça et ça
pousse à la conformité et une
standardisation
des attitudes des gens et ceux depuis
qu'ils sont tout petits. Et pourtant on
a besoin de cet espace de liberté de vie
privée hein. C'est un grand classique.
Si si quelqu'un chante sous la douche,
moi je sais quand je chante sous la
douche, je chante pas toujours très bien
et puis ben je m'améliore au fil du
temps. Mais s'il y a quelqu'un à côté,
j'entends une porte qui s'ouvre et je
sais que je suis entendu sous la douche
en train de mal chanter, ça coupe tout
parce que et ça ve parce que j'ose pas
exprimer ces difficultés, cet
apprentissage et et donc je je me tais.
Et si on se sent surveillé en
permanence, on va pas oser être
ridicule, on va pas oser essayer des
nouvelles choses. Ouais. Puis on va pas
oser être journaliste, on va pas oser
être juge et on va pas oser plein d'être
plein de trucs. Ce qui pour ajouter
quelque chose ici sur ce que tu dis
Tristan euh c'est très juste et ce dont
on parle ici, moi j'ai ça fait des ça
fait des années qu'on qu'on parle de ces
sujets là évidemment depuis depuis
Snowden là. On a on a un boulevard pour
s'exprimer sur ces questions et de plus
en plus de gens réalisent l'importance
de ça. Mais j'ai j'ai un vrai problème
quand on parle de protection de la vie
privée. Ah c'est une liberté
fondamentale voyez-vous. France, pays
des droits de l'homme, toutci tout ça.
Et beaucoup de gens s'en s'en cognent et
se disent "Bah moi, tant que j'ai pas
mangé, tant que je galère pour payer mon
loyer, qu'est-ce que j'irais m'emmerder
à défendre les libertés fondamentales ?"
En réalité, ce que tu décris ici,
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
personnel. On parle pas de protection de
vie privée, on parle d'intimité. Et
l'intimité, tout le monde en a une et
tout le monde comprend ça. L'intimité,
c'est ces moments dans lesquels on est
tout nu, au propre ou au figuré, dans
lesquels on est on est vraiment
soi-même, sans costume, sans masque,
sans rôle à jouer. On est en pleine
confiance, soit seul, soit avec les gens
avec qui on choisit de l'être. Et c'est
dans ces espaces que, comme tu dis, on
n'est pas jugé par ses pères. Et donc
c'est ça, c'est pas protéger une liberté
fondamentale, enfin c'est aussi ça, mais
avant tout c'est protéger nos intimités
et notre droit à l'intimité, vu que
c'est dans ces moments d'intimité que
l'on va pouvoir, comme tu dis avec
l'exemple de la douche, qu'on va pouvoir
expérimenter avec de nouvelles œuvres,
avec de nouvelles façons de chanter,
avec nouvelles idées, de nouvelles
opinions. Mais expérimenter implique de
se tromper, implique de ne pas se sentir
jugé par ses pères. Et sans cette
expérimentation et bien voilà, on ne
peut pas développer qui l'on est, on
peut pas développer son identité. Donc
c'est un combat pour nos intimité et
pour nos identités. Je je pour moi c'est
c'est essentiel qu'on a qu'on développe
ça de cette façonlà. On a on a Corben à
notre table. Salut Corben. Salut Manu.
Corben, quand tu entends alors je te tue
toi parce que voilà, tu es ni
journaliste ni acteur et puis la
collusion. Bon, je suis très fier
diffuse cette vidéo. Euh Corben, quand
tu entends ça là, qui est toi en tant
que père de famille, en tant
qu'internaute, qu'est-ce que ça te fait
? Moi, je suis sensible à tout ça, mais
pour moi, ce qu'on disait par rapport à
la aux lois qui ont été votées là après
les attentats de Charlie HBDo, pour moi
tout ça c'est quelque chose qui marche
depuis longtemps et c'est ce genre de
fait d'hiver comme disait Tristan, c'est
juste la bonne occase pour faire la
pilule quoi. Et c'est juste parce que
les enfin à mon sens l'appareil
politique a le contrôle sur pas mal de
choses, sur les médias, sur voilà ce qui
se dit et cetera. Internet, c'est un
outil qui est assez libre. N'importe
quel euh gars, voilà, euh décide de
d'ouvrir un site, de faire de mettre une
vidéo en ligne, de s'exprimer. Pour
avoir le contrôle là-dessus, c'est plus
compliqué et euh et passer par un juge,
c'est long. Donc, c'est vrai que le le
côté euh on a la petite loi, on a la
petite le petit levier administratif et
on peut bloquer tout ce qu'on veut.
C'est quand même très on va dire très
pratique puisque c'est un peu enfin pour
moi c'est c'est une volé, c'est surtout
très inefficace. Alors, ben on on l'a vu
là, je crois que c'était euh hier, le
piratbay.se a été bloqué au niveau DNS
par une autorité administrative. Donc
certains fournisseurs d'accès ont bloqué
le DNS et donc quand on essaie d'aller
sur
piratb.se on peut pas. Ah bon ?
Dramatique. Sauf qu'en fait ça ne fait
suer que les gens qui savent pas qu'on
peut utiliser un autre DNS qui lui n'est
pas bloqué. Donc en gros, ça n'emmerde
que les gens qui n'iraient pas sur
pirate B. C'est je t'arrête là-dessus
quand même parce que il y a ça c'est une
première méthode de blocage mais ça peut
monter assez vite crchendo c'estàd que
toi tu vas contourner ils vont remettre
un autre russe on va contourner et à un
moment on va arriver au DPI et on va
arriver à alors DPI alors 10 paquets
d'inspection c'estàd que en gros le
fournisseur d'accès va regarder ce qui
passe dans les dans les petits paquet va
tout éplucher et là pourra bloquer on va
dire à la source enfin nativement le
truc et donner l'alerte et donner
l'alerte et même si on passe par des
raisons on va dire darknet genre Thor ou
ou ce genre de choses.
Ça aussi ça peut être on va dire. Alors
au niveau de l'efficacité déjà petite
petite parenthèse petite parenthèse
purement sémantique le terme darknet je
pense a été inventé par nos ennemis pour
faire croire que ce qui est chiffré ou
anonyme sur internet c'est le mal. En
gros Eric Schmidt PDG de Google dit "Ah
bien sûr que vous pouvez être anonyme
sur internet. Si vous voulez être
anonyme sur internet, c'est que vous
avez un crime à commettre.
En gros, être anonyme sur internet,
c'est être impossible pour Google à
aspirer. Donc ça veut dire ne pas
générer de profit pour Google. Donc pour
Google, c'est
l'ennemi. Ce qu'on ce qui est appelé par
les journalistes non éduqués Darknet,
c'est la capacité de deux ordinateurs à
parler le protocole de leur choix, qu'il
soi chiffré ou non chiffré, anonyme ou
pas. Et cette capacité de deux
ordinateurs à parler le protocole de
leur choix sans intermédiaire, sans
garde barrière, c'est ce qu'on appelle
internet. Internet. Il m'a dit fait
malad Michu. Moi j'ai fait madame
Michu. Non mais merci Jérémy de rappeler
ça en gros ce qu'on appelle ce qu'on
appelle Darknet, c'est tout c'est toute
la partie d'internet qui n'est pas
accessible à Google et dans laquelle on
peut s'exprimer librement sans être
traqué. C'est l'internet qu'on veut.
C'est l'internet libre. Non mais
je et quand quand même nous on en vient
à se à se à à reprendre ces termes, mais
je je te je te dis ça sans sans
t'attaquer ou quoi parce que je connais
des gens qui sont qui sont enfin euh
voilà qui ont une réflexion sur le sujet
d'où l'importance du sens des mots et de
se battre pour le sens des mot fin de la
fin de la parent. Vous parlez vous
parlez du sens des mots. On beaucoup de
personnes ont vu Jérisy Zimmerman votre
vidéo lors de votre audition au Sénat.
Ah tu vous vois maintenant ? Bon je te
je te tue toi vous vois. Euh on a vu ta
vidéo du Sénat où tu as été euh un peu
véhément avec nos pauvres hommes
politiques. C'est c'est c'était très
intéressant sur la sémantique et sur la
sémiologie. Euh quelle est quelle est la
réaction que tu as face au trou noir des
politiques quant à leur perception de
des problématiques ? Qu'est-ce que ça te
fait en tant ? Tu étais amené à parler
de de surveillance, de problèmes de
société. C'est censé être leur créneau
et on voit bien qu'on fasse soit ils ont
un agenda, soit ils y projettent leur
peur mais la plupart du temps ils y
connaissent rien. Ils sont hostiles à ce
que moi ce que j'ai vu c'est qu'ils
étaient assez hostile à ce que Jérémy
disait quoi. J'ai B je je suis partagé
parce que d'un côté à titre personnel,
j'étais un petit peu excédé euh parce
que bon déjà parce que je suis plus
porte-parole de la quadrature du net, je
sentais ma parole un petit peu plus
libre et puis je fais un peu moins.
Disons que je suis plus financé pour
faire à pleinttemps ce genre de ce genre
de claque et que j'arrive dans une salle
au tris/4 vides avec en face de moi le
sénateur Jean-Pierre Sueur euh qui
défendait la la loi de programmation
militaire euh en expliquant que bien sûr
il y a des contrôles, il y a des trucs
les machins pas s'il s'est fait
intoxiquer par les services ou s'il
était tenu par tel ou tel secret ou et
pourquoi tu essayes pas de le piéger
quand tu es en face de quelqu'un comme
ça ? Pourquo tu dis pas comment vous
faites pour envoyer un mail ? Quel est
votre provider ? C'est pas le enfin je
pense que que c'est pas lieu. Donc
j'étais à titre personnel un petit peu
un petit peu sur les dents en plus avec
le contexte politique actuel euh voilà
en face de chez moi, j'ai des militaires
avec des des famasses chargées. Euh non,
ils sont pas chargés en fait. Non, j'ai
entendu dire qu'à ce niveau de vigie
pirateci, mais peut-être que j'étais
j'ai entendu dire qu'on était au plus
haut niveau de Vigj pirate où ça veut
dire que les armes sont chargées par
défaut. Mais je j'ai peut-être mais
c'est un secret finel. Mais en fait, il
paraît que non. D'accord. Mais mais il
faut pas dire qu'ils ont pas chargés
parce qu'évidemment on soutien au
militaire qui se qui se gè devant des
lieux. De toute façon pour moi ça
projette ni l'image d'une bonne gestion
des des finances publiques ni de la
sécurité de voir des petits jeunes de 19
ans en train de se geler les couilles
avec des armes automatiques à la main.
Tu peux pas tirer en ville avec un
famas, hein. Donc tu enfin à moins de
vouloir tuer des des des passons, hein.
Et et donc dans ce contexte là, j'étais
disons un petit peu un petit peu sur les
dents et et mais le le le fond de ce qui
m'a le plus euh ce qui m'a le plus
excédé, c'est d'avoir l'impression de
répéter les mêmes choses depuis 10 ans,
leur expliquer pourquoi la censure ça
marche pas, pourquoi c'est
contreproductif, pourquoi c'est une
spirale descendante dont on ne peut pas
remonter. Pourquoi ça conduit aux abus ?
C'est des argumentaires en tant que
quadrature. On les a écrit pour la
première fois en 2008 quand on venait de
se fonder. À chaque nouvelle loi
sécuritaire, on a répéter les mêmes
choses. À chaque loi sécuritaire, on
s'est fait balayer plus ou moins plus ou
moins rapidement. Les dernières, j'ai
raconté, c'était l'UMP et le PS qui
votaient ensemble les trucs en se en se
en s'applaudissant et l'impression que
ça n'est qu'une étape de plus comme ça a
été dit. Bon, j'aime pas trop le fait de
qualifier l'histoire de Charlie Hebdo et
de Hypercacher de fait d'hiver parce que
c'est un fait quand même exceptionnel.
C'est pas si divers que ça. Mais
effectivement, le premier fait venu, il
y aurait pas eu ça, ça aurait peut-être
été dans 3 mois, dans 4 mois, ça aurait
peut-être été un coup de couteau ici,
une bombinette là-bas. À ce niveau-là,
ça n'importe pas. C'est le premier truc
venu qui sert à faire avancer un agenda
qui existe déjà. Comme après le 11
septembre 2001, 3 semaines après le
patriot était voté aux États-Unis, on
n'écrit pas une loi comme le Patriotacte
en 3 semaines et ça a été documenté le
patriotte était déjà écrit avant. Et
Naomi Klein euh théorise ça très bien
dans son bouquin la théorie du choc, la
stratégie du choc euh en en expliquant
que c'est l'instrumentalisation des de
des peurs dans une opinion publique qui
se manipule, qui servent à faire avancer
un agenda politique qu'on narriverait
pas à rendre acceptable. autrement. Donc
c'est ça qui m'a vraiment mis euh par
terre et en gardant à l'esprit cette
citation épique pour expliquer pour
illustrer cette stratégie du choc et
surtout le rapport des politiques euh à
ces à cet agenda euh sécuritaire, c'est
Cameron interroger sur la la dernière
loi terro en date en Angleterre pour
dire "Je vote ça parce que je ne veux
pas être accusé lorsqu'il y aura un
attentat de ne pas avoir fait ce que
j'ai pu faire lorsque je pouvais le
une espèce de
paré du futur qui d'un point de vue
grammatical déjà a du mal à s'articuler
et qui montre que les politiques à force
de réagir le nez posé sur des des
chiffres de
sondage gouverne même plus aux
instruments mais gouverne à une
représentation en chiffre de l'émotion
des instruments qui sont ceux du pouvoir
et que du coup tout ça est ouvert à
toutes les manipulations et donc
l'impression d'aller au Sénat pour
pisser dans un violon parce qu'on sait
très bien que quel que soit et je ne
doute pas pour le coup des bonnes
intentions de la rapporteur la sénatrice
Goulet mais que queles que soient les
conclusions du rapport on va avoir dans
quelques semaines une nouvelle loi sur
le renseignement et que cette loi sur le
renseignement ça va être forcément plus
de surveillance plus de pouvoir à
l'exécutif et à la police moins de
judiciaire et qu'Internet va encore je
touvre une parenthèse. On a des contacts
to comme moi dans l'antiterro. Euh on ne
citera pas de nom aujourd'hui pour
l'avoir pour les avoir non pour les
avoir eu au téléphone il y a pas très
longtemps. Euh on va se mettre à leur
place. Il y a 20 % de turnover dans les
services de renseignement intérieur. Il
y a un burnout de certains. Tu peux pas
parler français hein. Ouais. Les gens
sont fatigués. Les gens sont
fatigués. Pour certains, on leur donne
pas de moyens. Ils sont obligés
d'imprimer les blocs des des attentats.
Pas des attentats, mais des des
radicaux. islamiste parce que ils ont
aucune aucun périphérique sécurisé, ils
ont peur, ils sont pas ils sont pas
renseignés. Je vais revenir devant
Tristan. Est-ce que dans ton rapport en
studio maintenant, est-ce que dans ton
dans ton rapport dans ta thèse, tu émets
des
préconisations pour les politiques ou
pour la population ? Quelles sont
quelles sont tes préconisations ? Alors,
il y a il y en a quatre plus
une préalable. Premièrement, il faut se
documenter. Il faut essayer de
comprendre comment ça marche tout ça
plutôt que de se laisser euh comment
fait bah c'est pour ça que j'écris le
livre euh qui est vraiment fait pour euh
euh rendre abordable toute cette
problématique. Pourquoi il faut la vie
privée ? Euh qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'internet ? Qu'est-ce que c'est que le
cloud, hein ? Enfin concrètement, le
cloud, ça veut dire qu'on utilise
l'ordinateur de quelqu'un d'autre. C'est
faut faut le comprendre comme ça. Et
puis après, il y a quatre pistes à
étudier. Euh la première, c'est
d'utiliser du logiciel libre,
c'est-à-dire du logiciel dont on peut
voir et comprendre le code source pour
voir ce qu'il fait. Ça c'est absolument
indispensable. On essaie de nous faire
comprendre que euh c'est une idée de IPI
euh la vérité que c'est c'est ce qui
fait tourner le monde et ce qui fait de
droit de le droit de le on dit. Voilà.
Euh pour moi, c'est essentiel si on veut
contrôler et avoir sa liberté euh avec
le numérique qui monte chaque jour en
puissance, il faut utiliser des
logiciels libres. Premièrement. Euh
deuxièmement, euh il va falloir utiliser
du chiffrement, ce qu'on appelle aussi
de la crypto, c'est-à-dire que les
échanges qu'on fait sur internet et
autres, il faut utiliser du chiffrement.
Ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut que nous
informaticien on rende le chiffrement
facile à utiliser. Puis une clé de
chiffrement au dehors qu'une clé de
chiffrement américaine, ce serait bien.
On va commencer doucement déjà essayer
d'expliquer ce que c'est que le
chiffrement et commencer à s'en servir
le plus possible pour éviter les grandes
oreilles, pour éviter l'espionnage
économique. Et vous avez pas vous avez
pas l'impression qu' en ayant ce type de
préconisation, vous renforcez les
terroristes en face de vous ?
Non.
Je suis sûr que j'ai mis trè bon troll.
Oui. Ouais, je suis obligé de faire le
troll. Non non, il faut euh je je il
faut se protéger de toute façon parce
que il y a un gros problème aujourd'hui,
c'est quand on voit euh dans les
révélations Snowden, donc le le lanceur
d'alerte Édouard Snowden qui a
communiqué des documents de la NSA à des
journalistes en juin 2013, euh quand on
fouille un petit peu ce qu'il y a dans
cette énorme documentation, probablement
des millions de documents, euh on voit
très bien que en fait les vrais clients
de la NSA euh ça va être le ministère de
l'agriculture américain,
Euh ça va être le ministère du commerce,
c'est de l'espionnage industriel, voilà,
économique et pas simplement de la lutte
antiterroriste ou anti même pas même pas
simplement, c'est que c'est un rapport
de la New America Foundation et je crois
qu'il y a un rapport d'une commission
consultative de la Maison Blanche qui
arrive à peu près aux même conclusion,
la New America Foundation avait trouvé
que c'est dans moins de 1 % des cas
d'attentats terroristes déjoués qui a eu
besoin de la surveillance de masse. Donc
ça n'a absolument aucun impact sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme. Alors là on
a fait le au niveau des préconication on
donc il en reste deux puisque la
troisième ça va être l'autohébergement
c'est-à-dire faire tourner si on a des
besoins de de cloud c'est de d'un
serveur il faut pas que ça tourne chez
Google mais il faut le tourner faire
fonctionner sur un ordinateur sur lequel
on a le contrôle donc ça va être
probablement de
l'autohébergement donc avoir une boîte
peut-être que ça serait à terme notre
box internet où on pourrait stocker nos
propres données. Et puis quatrièmement,
4rième piste, ça va être changer le
business model des services d'internet
aujourd'hui. Parce qu'aujourd'hui, le le
truc qui fait tourner l'internet
commercial, c'est la publicité ciblée.
Et la publicité ciblée, ça consiste à
savoir un maximum de choses sur
l'utilisateur pour ensuite monétiser ce
savoir, ce profil sur l'utilisateur, le
monétiser auprès d'annonceur. Et là, on
comprend en fait que les annonceurs,
c'est les vraiment les clients de
Google, de Twitter et de Facebook. C'est
eux qui paye, qui passent la commande.
Il passent la commande et nous en fait,
on est le produit qui est vendu à ces
annonceurs. Il y a il y a une très belle
illustration qui est qui est dans mon
livre où on voit deux cochons qui sont
dans une porcherie et le premier qui dit
à l'autre "Ah, tu as vu, c'est génial,
la nourriture est gratuite ici." et
l'autre lui répond et en plus on est
logé gratuitement. Et la légende de de
de cette illustration c'est deux cochons
discutant du modèle gratuit parce que
les voilà les deux les cochons, c'est
nous on va finir d'ébiter en saucisse et
parce que nous on est on est le produit
qui est vendu aux vrais clients qui sont
les les annonceurs. Et une fois qu'on
aura résolu ce problème de business
model et qu'on aura compris que si on
veut un service de qualité au service de
l'utilisateur, il faut payer pas
forcément beaucoup. Et bien là, on va
réussir à avoir le contrôle sur
l'internet. Corben. Oui. Alors, on est
des cottelettes.
Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que tu as
l'impression qu'on est des cotelettes ?
Euh ouais, totalement. Oui. Enfin, tu
vois comment dans ta vie de tous les
jours ? Euh bah moi, je vois qu'autour
de moi, tout le monde utilise Gmail.
Rien que ça déjà si les gens se
passaient de Gmail, ça serait déjà beau.
Pourquoi ? Et toi, tu utilises plus
Gmail. Alors, tu utilises quoi à la
place ? Moi je suis passé alors moi, je
suis pas passé en autohébergement au
niveau des mails, mais je suis passé
chez ovh. Donc tu payes donc tu payes.
Donc je paye. C'est voilà. Mais
effectivement, ça a un prix aussi ça de
toute façon la vie enfin mais c'est très
bien que tu payes hein. Je pense que tu
as compris que justement et enfin de
tout le sujet dont on parle, il y a un
investissement que ça soit financier ou
que ça soit en terme de connaissance et
d'implication technique pour s'y mettre
et monter son petit truc chez soi, il
faut quand même y aller quoi. Si on
reste comme des
vau voilà, un peu comme les gens qui
regardent la télé qui font que regarder
la télé, s'ils vont pas se documenter
eux-mêmes sur le net, ils vont pas voilà
essayer de rencontrer des gens et cetera
et ben leur seule fenêtre vers le monde
c'est la télé. C'est la même chose avec
ce qu'on fait au niveau enfin avec les
services qu'on utilise au quotidien. Si
on est abrevé, bah comme les cochons
avec la nourriture gratuite, bah on la
mange et on réfléchit pas et puis on
puit en saucisson. On finit d'habiter en
saucisson. Donc voilà, c'est Jérémy, je
vais revenir dans un instant sur cette
sur cette démarche active plus qu'à
l'information, à la connaissance parce
que je pense que c'est la clé. Juste à
porter une précision ou deux. Tristan,
quand tu dis il faut de la crypto, oui,
mais il faut de la crypto de bout en
bout. C'est ce qu'on appelle end toend
encryption en anglais par opposition à
la crypto de point à point euh à savoir
la crypto dans lequel l'utilisateur
génère une clé, l'autre utilisateur
génère une clé par un échange de clé
publique. On s'assure de pouvoir
communiquer par un canal que l'on estime
de confiance sans avoir besoin de faire
confiance à qui que ce soit d'autre.
C'est pas Apple qui a la clé, Google qui
a la clé, le certificateur du
certificateur du certificateur du machin
qui a la clé comme quand on utilise
HTTPS. Non non, c'est des produits qui
font ça bien sûr, il y a GPG pour le
mail, il y a OTR of the record pour le
chat, euh il y a Text Secure et
Redphone, même s'ils sont distribués un
petit peu bizarrement sur Android, euh
on pourrait publier sur le site de
Tinkerview euh ben un lien vers le par
exemple le le blog de de Corben qui
référence ça ou le site
contrôlesonnées.net.
Mais c'est pas c'est pas l'objet ici.
Juste que philosophiquement et
technologiquement, c'est quelque chose
de très différent. C'est la crypto qui
est aux mains de l'utilisateur par
rapport à juste la crypto. Euh aussi
rajouter un petit point, quand tu dis
autohébergement, je suis d'accord, c'est
l'objectif, mais l'autohébergement c'est
l'aboutissement, c'est le degré ultime
de la décentralisation des services et
des communications. Ce que l'on vit,
c'est la décentralisation. Au lieu en
attendant d'avoir ma Freedom Box, le
professeur Eben Moglen, le grand phare
dans la nuit inspiration, l'immense
professeur Eben Moglen a expliqué en
2010 déjà sa vision pour une Freedom Box
qui conduisait à nous nous permettre de
décentraliser les services et les
communications. En attendant d'avoir ce
gadget que l'on doit faire avancer, qui
n'avance pas aussi vite qu'il devrait et
qu'on devrait rendre aussi sexy qu'un
iPhone. le petit bidule qu'on met dans
une prise et pic, ça y est, on a ses
images chez soi, ses mails chez soi, on
décide de partager avec qui on veut, il
y a crypto qui marche comme ça et
cetera. En attendant d'avoir ça, si
c'est mutualisé à l'échelle d'une bande
de potes, à l'échelle d'une association,
d'une entreprise ou même d'une
administration publique, c'est déjà
vachement mieux que tout mettre chez
Google nous avant. Donc le le le
l'objectif c'est la décentralisation et
l'autohébergement c'est l'aboutissement
de ça. Maintenant, ce que je voulais
ajouter là-dessus, c'est que quand on
regarde ces technologies qui libèrent,
logiciel libre, décentralisation des
services et chiffrement de bout en bout,
ils sont dans le miroir des
caractéristiques des technologies qui
contrôlent, qui sont logiciel et
matériel fermés pour qu'on puisse pas
savoir ce qu'ils font, services
centralisés pour agréger masse de
données, les recouper entre elles,
profiler profiter euh et le le faux la
fa l'illusion de sécurité, le petit
cadna, tu fermes les yeux, tu fais
confiance à Google et tout marche très
bien. Ces trois caractéristiques des
technologies qui contrôlent reposent sur
le même mécanisme qui est de soustraire
à l'utilisateur la capacité de
comprendre. Si tu as pas le code source
du logiciel, si tu as pu c'est une boîte
noire soudée entre 18 couches d'époxy
dans un bidule que tu peux de toute
façon même pas
ouvrir. Si tu as l'illusion de sécurité
parce qu'on te t'explique pas comment ça
fonctionne, si j'ai eu cette anecdote
charmante sur quelqu'un qui propose à sa
grand-mère, "Mamie, tu veux regarder tes
mails de mon ordinateur ?" et la
grand-mère qui en toute bonne fois je
dit bah non je peux pas ils sont sur mon
ordinateur qui se rendit pas compte que
se connecter à Google c'était se
connecter à Gmail c'était se connecter à
un ordinateur distant bah non ça
apparaît dans mon ordinateur donc mes
mails sont dans mon ordinateur tant
qu'on a pas conscience de l'architecture
technopolitique des services et des
communications que l'on utilise alors on
on est dans l'ignorance et donc c'est
cette ignorance qui est à dessin
construite par les fabricants et cette
alliance entre les fabricants et les
politiques pour nous maintenir dans
l'ignorance pour mieux nous contrôler.
Alors qu'en face le logiciel libre, les
services décentralisés et le chiffrement
de bout en bout sont des technologies
qui certent peuvent paraître un petit
peu difficiles à apprendre qui
nécessitent une prise en main, un
apprentissage une appropriation
peut-être une volonté une volonté. Mon
mon point ici c'est que ça n'est que si
on s'approprie ces technologies qui
libèrent que l'on sera vraiment libre.
Et ce qu'il y a entre nous et cette
appropriation, la plupart du temps,
c'est d'un côté le marketing tout
souriant, on est vos amis, euh Apple te
fait avoir l'air tellement intelligent,
Google te dit "On do not do not do
evol". Et cetera et de l'autre côté,
parce que ça ça n'est qu'une partie de
la médaille, de l'autre côté une espèce
de sentiment de technophobie ambiante.
Ah mais moi tous ces trucs là, ah je
peux pas parce que je ne suis pas X Y ou
Z, je ne suis pas un génie, un hackur,
un heur d'un
machin pas comprendre. Pourquoi pas
expliquer les choses différemment ?
c'est que en réalité la seule chose qui
bloque les utilisateurs des technologies
qui libèrent c'est une un apprentissage,
c'est une appropriation et c'est en
anglais, il y a cette notion
d'empowerment qui n'existe qu'en
espagnol d'Amérique latine, mientento
qui existe pas en espagnol espagnol et
qui à ma connaissance existe pas en
français autrement traduit que par
capacitation qui est moche. Parce que
dans empowerment et dans empoderamiento,
il y a cette notion de pouvoir. Ça veut
dire se pas prendre le pouvoir mais
devenir accaparer ce pouvoir,
s'approprier s'approprier le pouvoir. Et
la première étape pour s'approprier le
pouvoir, c'est de comprendre le pouvoir
que l'on a. Manu l'a dit, pour compléter
ce que dit Jérémy, moi ce que j'ai
remarqué depuis Snowden, c'est que il y
a de plus en plus de solutions, de plus
en plus de solutions et de services qui
sortent qui sont orientés user friendly,
enfin qui sont simples à comprendre.
simple à utiliser. Alors, c'est pas
encore parfait. Euh là où il y a un truc
qui pêche, c'est que
forcément une solution email, même si
elle est super chiffrée, même si elle
est très sécurisée, elle sera en terme
de fonctionnalité encore moins bien que
Gmail. Par exemple, moi, bon voilà, j'ai
j'ai un service de mail qui est pas
Gmail. Euh je galère quand je veux faire
une recherche parmi mes 418000 mail, bah
c'est compliqué. Alors qu'avec Gmail, je
tapé un mot clé, je le retrouvais tout
de suite. Et ce que je veux, je trouve
ça complètement nul.
Ce que non mais ce que je veux dire ce
que je veux dire par là, c'est qu'en
fait ce choix là peut se faire
techniquement mais ça entraîne en fait
une
une notion de perte de confort sur les
outils en tout cas actuellement parce
que c'est pas encore assez développé,
c'est pas encore assez travaillé parce
que les mecs qui font ça c'est des
barbus et ils ont pas forcément les
notions de qualité qu'on Google quand
ils font des produits finis bien en bien
emballés avec le sourire comme disait
Jérémy. Voilà. Donc cette perte de
confort, il faut la il faut l'accepter,
il faut la comprendre. C'est comme les
gens qui passent sous Linux, qui passent
sur logiciel libre, ils vont se dire "Ah
ouais mais c'est chiant, faut compiler,
faut machin." C'est compliqué, enfin
c'est pas agréable, les fonds d'écran
sont pas jolis, la barre elle est pas
belle, enfin peu importe. Mais c'est
c'est de la perte de confort, mais d'un
autre côté on gagne en terme de et j'ai
j'ai une petite analogie pour troller
sur moi je te trollle avant. Je te
trollle avant. Ouais. Non, d'abord non
la pourquoi pas expliquer les choses
suivantes. Alors, vous savez que sur
notre chaîne YouTube, on s'intéresse aux
problèmes géopolitiques, géostratégie et
financier. Qu'on a l'opportunité de
parler à des grands financiers et des
des gens en poste ou ayant été en poste.
Nous nous on voit un petit peu une
parallèle entre la surveillance
d'Internet, le fliquage
généralisé sous des prétextes, sous le
faux prétexte et on voit aussi le climat
économique devenir complètement
délétaire. Et et la grande peur qu'on a
sur notre chaîne YouTube, c'est est-ce
que ce n'est pas une façon comme une
autre d'anticiper un gros bordel
économique, c'est-à-dire de préparer des
outils sur internet pour pouvoir
enquiller ou ficher ou surveiller des
gens n'ayant pas la même vision
économique que le capitalisme des des
dégénérés. Donc nous nous c'est notre
question, c'est-à-dire que plus la la
finance est dérégulée, plus on voit la
dérégulation d'internet au mauvais sens
du terme à à arriver. Et quand on vous
pose des questions, vous avez très peu
de passerelles vous dans votre milieu
avec des financiers, avec des gens
acteurs sur les places de marché, avec
des directeurs de banque, avec ces
choses-là. Donc moi la la question que
mes auditeurs me posent, c'est est-ce
que c'est pas encore un éème dispositif
pour pouvoir nous visser et nous mettre
une camisole numérique en cas
d'effondrement économique ou en cas de
tension économique ? C'est ça ton troll
? Ouais, vas-y troll. Non, il est bon.
Il est bon. Du coup, ça m'empêche un peu
de revenir sur le point précédent
comm sur cette notion de perte de
confort, imagine des gens qui se disent
bah, ils sont bien gentils à vouloir
abolir l'esclavage mais c'est quand même
vachement confortable les esclaves.
Regarde, construisez une maison, hop,
elle est construite. Tu vois, tu es
obligé d'en abattre un quand même pour
l'exemple. Oui, mais bon, tu tu
délègues, tu délègues. Euh de la même
façon, le vote des femmes, bah ça devait
être bien confortable avant pour ceux
qui étaient pas des femmes de pouvoir
décider de ce qu'allait être les les les
dirig d'information, on a on a permis le
vote des fans pour les taxer hein. Tout
tout ce que je veux dire ici, c'est
qu'il y a à des moments des choix de
société qui sont tellement importants
qu'il justifient qu'on se passe d'une
partie de nos modes de vie à entendre en
écho de ce que George Bush a dit le jour
où il a été élu, je crois, dire notre
mode de vie n'est pas négociable.
Donc ça peut être perçu comme une perte
de confort, mais quand c'est pour
atteindre des objectifs supérieurs,
c'est des choix de société qu'on est
capable de faire, qu'on a déjà été dans
l'histoire capable de faire, même si le
droit des femmes aujourd'hui est pas
dans le monde entier euh uniform.
Christine Lagarde a dit qu'il y avait
pas de problème avec l'Arabie Saoudite.
Ouis. Maintenant, pour revenir sur ta
question euh et le fait d'anticiper les
crises, euh que la surveillance de masse
soit un outil de contrôle social, euh je
pense que c'est évident. ce que ce
qu'évoquait Tristan à l'heure sur
l'autocensure, c'est pas juste
l'autocensure Jérémie, merde à l'heure
actuelle la surveillance de masse, on
est plus à l'époque de la stasie
l'époque de nos grands-parents où ils
faisaient tous des fiches et qui
plaçaient des micros chez toi à
l'arrache des micros qui étaient la
taille de mon téléphone portable. Là, on
passe à Là, on passe à la surveillance
de masse plus la loi de mour,
c'est-à-dire le doublement des capacités
des composants électronique tous les 2
ans. Et on va se retrouver d'ici 3 ans
avec une machine ayant des capacités
dignes de superhéros. Non non mais
attends, on est déjà dans des capacités
dingues. Il faut garder à l'esprit que
les documents de Snowden datent de 2012
que ça va bientôt faire 3 ans. Donc ta
loi de mour elle voilà tues 3 ans, on
s'est déjà pris dans le vent. Quand on
lisait en 2012 que la NSA était emmerdée
par Thort, peut-être qu'aujourd'hui il
le casse comme ça. Quand on lisait en
2012 qu'ils avaient pas la baguette
magique pour faire péter la crypto, si
ça se trouve, ils font péter la crypto
et cetera. Donc on est déjà peut-être
dépassé par ce que l'on connaît et ce
que l'on connaît est une échelle qui
nous nous a tous fait tomber de la
chaise, même ceux qui étaient qualifiés
de plus paranoïqu ceux qui étaient le
plus prudents avant. Donc je je suis
d'accord avec toi et et je te dis que
c'est presque un c'est presque imponsif
aujourd'hui de dire que cette
surveillance va permettre de le contrôle
social. C'est son objectif premier.
C'était c'est ta perception de la chose.
Elle a été votée au nom de la lutte
contre le terrorisme. On a maintenant
démontré par A + B qu'elle ne sert à
rien contre le terrorisme mais qu'elle
est utilisée à défionnages industriels
et d'espionnages politiques. Ce que l'on
sait c'est qu'elle est un outil de
contrôle social et ça de façon homogène
dans dans l'histoire. Certes, laasie
c'était pas des enfants de cœur non
plus. Il y avait un informateur de la
stasie par 400 habitants. Ça veut dire
en gros un par pâté de maison. Jamais
une police secrète n'a été aussi
densément informée par sa population. et
des micros, il y en avait de de dizaines
de types différents et il y avait un
joli arsenal. Mais oui, on est déjà bien
plus loin que la stthasie. Mais laasie
servait avant tout d'instrument de
contrôle social pour maintenir le régime
en place et de façon consistante dans
l'histoire. Chaque fois qu'il y a eu
surveillance de masse, c'était des
régimes autoritaires qui contrôlaient
leur population. Donc oui, c'est
évidemment la situation dans laquelle on
est. Maintenant, ce que je voulais
ajouter et peut-être que c'est ça qui va
intéresser tes amis financiers ou les
gens qui se posent des questions un peu
plus prospectives qui raisonnent en
terme un petit peu plus euh lointain que
la prochaine élection par exemple, euh
c'est que dans un modèle de société dans
lesquels les individus sont
empowered par l'appropriation de la
technologie, par le logiciel libre, les
services décentralisés, le chiffrement
de bout en bout, ont bâtit un modèle de
sécurité alternatif au modèle de
sécurité central. centralisé dans lequel
l'État comprend tout, entend tout et
peut influer sur tout laquelle l'État
décide de quels sites seront accessibles
ou pas accessibles, de quel de de quelle
communication sera écoutée ou non.
Lorsque l'on rend les individus en
quelque sorte responsables d'une partie
de leur leur communication, de la
sécurité de leurs données et de leur
communication, ont bâti un modèle de
sécurité plus décentralisé que le modèle
de sécurité centralisé. Et donc par là,
on bâtit de la résilience. La
résilience, c'est la capacité à se
remettre debout en cas d'attaque, que
l'on parle d'attaque terroriste,
d'attaque économique ou que l'on parle
de catastrophe naturelle. Et je pense
que c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
travailler. C'est sur développer
ensemble socialement à titre collectif
une capacité à bâtir de la résilience
informatique, de la résilience
information. Arrive pas. Ben si on y
arrive pas, c'est laisser les
entreprises américaines et les services
américains parce qu'ils sont plus
puissants, parce qu'ils ont un budget
d'ordre de magnitude au-delà des nôtres,
prendre le contrôle de nos économies et
de nos systèmes politiques.
Tristan, si on y arrive pas, tu fais
quoi ? Tu quittes la France ? Non, ça
sera pas pire ici qu'ailleurs. J'en sais
rien. Mais je prendrai les armes. Ouais,
tu prendras les armes ? les armes
numériques. Mais oui, des grenades
numériques, des lances-roquettes
numériques. Non, mais ça attention les
gars,
coupez. Tu prends Non non mais ça je
ferai acte de résistance et là ça va
passer. Jér toi ? Les armes
non couler le sang. Faire couler le sang
Non, je j' pas prêt à couler devant une
préfecture
aujourd'hui ? Non.
peut-être parce que je pense qu'il y a
des il y a des forcément des tactiques
plus efficaces que ça. Euh écoute, par
définition, s'ol devant quelque chose,
c'est la la c'est la tactique d'un
désespéré. Si un jour je suis désespéré,
je suis incapable de dire aujourd'hui ce
que je ferais. Et je suis persuadé, je
t'appellerai avant, on ira se boire un
petit coup. Mais je suis persuadé qu'on
a aujourd'hui une diversité quasi
infinie de tactique qui n'ont pas encore
été exploré et qui reposent précisément
sur ces technologies qu'on qu'on décrit.
Cette appropriation repose sur le
partage de la connaissance. Et ça c'est
quelque chose dont on est tous capable.
Il suffit d'avoir un cerveau, une
bouche, peut-être même pas, peut-être
juste des des mains sur un clavier, ça
suffit. Il suffit d'être un être humain
pour être en capacité de partager la
connaissance et je pense que ce partage
la connaissance est la clé pour
s'autonomiser et pour bâtir ensemble
cette résilience. On passe la la la
parole à Corben qui a comme slogan et
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de Corben
et de gens qui le slogan de Corben,
c'est upgrade your mind. Ouais, c'est
vieux ça. Mais oui oui. Qu'est-ce que tu
en penses Corben ? Moi je suis assez
confiant. Ouais. Euh je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi. Euh pour moi ce
ce enfin cette surveillance, la
publicité, la le ciblage, c'est né euh
c'est né tout ça de la publicité comme
disait euh comme disait Trist. Donc de
l'argent de voilà besoin de faire du
business. Là-dessus se sont greffés les
gouvernements parce qu'effectivement
c'est bien pratique d'avoir un Facebook
pour aller piocher dedans. Ça finance
aussi les campagnes hein.
Et ouais aussi.
Euh et je pense que avec ce qui se passe
en ce moment, avec le le aussi, bon ça
va prendre du temps encore, ça va
prendre plusieurs années, mais le le
côté on va dire euh éducatif, la
connaissance, le le fait euh comme euh
voilà, Jéris, ça fait 10 ans que je
ramasse la même chose, mais voilà, ce
genre de chos euh au bout d'un moment,
il va y avoir quand même des boîtes qui
vont se monter, les hackeurs qui vont
réagir, des business modèles qui vont se
monter, des choses qui vont être
payantes, qui vont être voilà qui qui
vont se financer et qui vont
baser leur business model comme on le
voit maintenant par exemple sur le bio
ou sur genre de choses qui vont baser
leur business model sur sur la vie
privée sur sur voilà le le chiffrement
sur le respect de tout ça et peut-être
que ça nous ouvrira des portes de
sortie. Euh alors j'ouvre juste une
parenthèse et je vous repasse la parole
à tous les deux. Euh je je tiens à dire
que j'ai j'ai essayé de faire venir un
représentant du ministère de
l'intérieur, monsieur Jérémy
rappelle-moi. La tournerie. La
tournerie. Alors, on a eu sa secrétaire
qui était
pas en elle était pas capable de me
donner autre chose qu'une femme de
ménage ou une assistante et encore, ils
ont pas voulu se déplacer. Même un
second couteau ayant la parole du
ministère, c'était pas possible. On a
contacté aussi Urvois pour qu'il vienne
un petit peu nous parler. Le député en
charge de ces question loi sur
l'intelligence. Tout à fait. Très
occupé. Très occupé. Et on avait convié
Jean-Marc Manac. Mais Manac, tu t'es
dégonflé et on va pas on va s'en on va
s'en rappeler, mec. Tu t'es bien
dégonflé. Moi j'aimerais dire ce que tu
dis. C'est c'est pas pour essayer de de
un optimiste. Non non non, mais je pense
qu' qu'il faut et de toute façon nul
n'it besoin d'espérer pour entreprendre.
Euh combien de temps ça va nous prendre
? Sachant que un les prochaines lois
sont déjà en train de d'être d'être
adopté quasiment. Euh et sachant que une
entreprise comme Apple, j'ai vu ce
chiffre là ces jours-ci est maintenant
évaluée à 400 milliards de dollars en
bourse. Donc si Apple claque des doigts
et éternue un petit milliard de dollars
pour faire du marketing en disant "Eh,
regardez, le nouvel iPhone 18 est
chiffré, logiciel libre, tout ce que
vous voulez, c'est la solution machin,
ils sont déjà en train de le faire. Euh
Google est en train de dire que oui,
mais en fait, on lutte contre ces
requêtes du gouvernement qui va accéder
à nos données et cetera. que que faire
contre tu sais il y a il y a le le green
washing en matière d'écologie où Total
va investir
0,001 % de ses revenus pour pardon
planter trois arbres quelque part en
Afrique et dire regardez Total c'est
l'écologie. Euh là, je pense qu'on est
en train déjà d'assister à une espèce de
le privacy washing ou quelque chose
privacy washing, un freedom washing dans
lequel tu as un machin qui sort, dit
"Oui, c'est chiffré." Et oui, comment
vous savez ? Exactement. Exactement. Ce
matin sur Twitter, je dis "Regardez,
avec Apple, il y a un problème parce un
des chapitres de mon livre que donc je
publie en simultanée sur mon blog et là,
on m'interpelle." "Ah oui, mais alors
attendez, c'est quand même, regardez ce
qu'ils font." Et on m'envoie un lien
vers un privacy white paper de de chez
Apple. et je regarde alors oui le machin
il fait je sais pas combien de dizaines
de pages. D'accord. Et tu as de schéma.
Ça a l'air vachement mais je peux rien
vérifier de ce qu'il y a dedans quoi. Si
tu peux le vérifier d'une façon tu peux
le vérifier sans ouvrir le document. Tu
le vérifies en mettant bout à bout le
Patriot Act et le Fa Amendment Act de
2008 qui ensemble font que Apple ne peut
pas refuser à la NSA d'accéder à toutes
ces données et aux données de tous ses
clients. Mais je parlais pas de ces
boîtes là moi. Non non non mais que que
des petites boîtes mignonnes et tout
émergent genre oui on va faire des Ubun
to fun des Firefox truc des machins. Il
y a GSMK en Allemagne, nos amis Andy
Mouor Magoun et Frankck Riger, gens du
historiquement du CCC qui font le
cryptophone. Ça fait 10 ans qu'il bosse
dessus. Le machin, il vaut 5 ou 6000 €
parce que ça fait 10 ans qu'il y a une
équipe de digus qui bosse dessus et
c'est pas du logiciel libre. Donc
commencer aujourd'hui un truc de zéro,
ça va prendre un temps fou. Moi ce que
je veux ajouter, je suis d'accord avec
toi et je suis d'accord avec toi en ce
sens qu'il y a un boulevard de marché
s'il faut parler dans ces termes-là pour
la protection de la vie privée. C'est
pas que les clients de c'est un appel au
chef d'entreprise que tu fais là. C'est
c'est pas un appel. Chacun trouvera ce
qu'il veut entendre. Je pas je pas
sortir la trompette.
Mais il y a pas que les gens prêts à
dépenser 5 ou 6000 € pour un cryptophone
de GSMK qui ont un intérêt économique ou
politique à protéger leur vie privée. Ce
que je veux dire, c'est que l'approche
de dire "Oh, le marché va régler ça, on
l'a entendu sur des questions qui
avaient très à l'environnement, la
dette, la dette de la Grèce, euh la
dette de la Grèce, le système financier
et cetera.
Et on peut se dire que ça marche pas
forcément ou en tout cas on peut
investir dans d'autres modes d'action
que ceux qui consistent à dire on va
laisser faire le marché les entreprises
en parallèle des fois que ça marche pas.
Et ce que je veux dire, on a évoqué ça
tout à l'heure, mais on n'est pas allé
au fond du du sujet, donc j'ai envie de
revenir là-dessus sur les
recommandations aux politiques. Parce
que que le marché règle son truc dans
son coin, c'est très bien mais quit de
politique publique, quit de la mission
d'élus dont la la responsabilité est de
protéger nos libertés fondamentales. Non
mais j'ouvre une parenthèse là et je je
fais le tr non, je fais le tr qui tient
qui tient les finances des partis
politiques ? Qui finance les les
trésoreries de partis politiques.
Attends, je suis en train de faire de la
science-fiction. Je suis en train de
faire de la science-fiction. Je te je te
parle de gens qui sont à la tête
d'institutions qui sont en train de
perdre leur légitimité, qui sont en
train de voir pour les plus lucides
arriver le spectre d'une vague brune,
marine ou de machin comme ça au travers
de de toute l'Europe. Et on va leur
laisser des outils extraordinaires et
qui se retrouveront à la tête de
l'appareil de de surveillance et
contrôle social qu'on est en train de
bâtir pour eux. Euh maintenant, je te
parle de ces institutions et peut-être
plus que des élus, des haut
fonctionnaires et des gens qui dans les
institutions n'ont pas la liberté de
parole mais qui voient très bien ce qui
est en train de se passer. et qui eux
ont une certaine marge de manœuvre, qui
eux peuvent appuyer certaines certaines
manettes, certaines certains boutons qui
peuvent écrire des notes, qui peuvent
faire des suggestions, qui peuvent
murmurer à l'oreille de ceux qui parlent
face caméra, qui savent pas de quoi il
parlent et que quand il s'agit de
politique publique, oui, logiciel libre,
système décentralisé, échiffrement de
bout en bout, ça devrait être un
objectif stratégique, ça devrait être
une politique industrielle si on en
avait le courage. Attends, attends,
attends, attends, j'y arrive, j'y
arrive. Ça devrait être une politique
industrielle par et là on peut on peut
s'asseoir avec une bouteille ou deux et
quelques experts et prendre le temps de
détailler ça. C'est qu'un embrillon de
liste. Ça pourrait être la commande
publique. On investit des doners
publics, ça devient des logiciels
publics, donc des logiciels libres. Ça
pourrait être par les les programmes de
l'éducation supérieure. On va te prendre
dans l'éducation nationale, on va
t'apprendre l'informatique, oui, mais ce
sera l'informatique libre. Euh ça
pourrait être par les les les budgets
euh des militaires et de la police en
matière de sécurité informatique. Un
machin comme l'ANSY avec ses 350 à cœur
de talent qui développe des téléphones
sécurisés basés sur Android pour en
faire tourner 900 exemplaires pour les
ministres et leur entourage. Pourquoi
moi citoyen français qui finance l'ANC,
j'ai pas ce sexroï dans ma poche ? Donc
il y a plein de biais par lesquels on
pourrait ça peut être aussi de
l'incitation fiscale dire une entreprise
si elle prouve que tout ce qu'elle
produit c'est sous GPL une licence de
logiciel libre alors sa TVA claque
claque claque parce qu'elle reverse déjà
la société au lieu voilà pour l'intérêt
général. Donc ça c'est donc créer le
contexte politique qui fera euh qui
permettra de faire arriver de de telles
mesures est aussi un objectif
aujourd'hui. Mais ce que je veux ajouter
ici c'est que le logiciel libre par
définition c'est un terrain d'entente
commun entre des gens qui ont des
intérêts potentiellement complètement
divers. C'està-dire que la NSA, Talès,
l'AN et l'équivalent de La Togo peuvent
au même moment bosser sur l'Audit du
même code, identifier des trous de
sécurité et soumettre des patchs. C'est
un terrain communquel on peut travailler
ensemble. Donc peut-être que ça se fera
pas en France, peut-être que ça se fera
pas en Europe, peut-être que ça se fera
au Brésil, en Inde ou dans dans un pays
dont on est même pas fichu de donner le
nom de la capital. Peut-être que ça se
fera ailleurs et par définition le
logiciel libre permet que où que ce soit
que cela se fasse, c'est l'intérêt
général. Tuas une vision Tu as une
vision gauliste de de de du mec qui va
s'expatrier pour pouvoir sauver son
territoire. C'est ça. Je je te dis les
analogies historiques, c'est pas mon
corben, qu'est-ce que tu en penses au
niveau de ces préconisations ? On
comprend bien, c'est très facile à
mettre en place. Ce qu'il faut, c'est
une volonté. Bah, il y a pas de volonté
politique. Et moi
j'ai avec des amis qui bossent ou qui
bossaient un peu plus haut dans les
ministères et quand ils ont un sujet
qu'ils ne connaissent pas, bah ils vont
se renseigner et qu'est-ce qui les
renseigne ? les les industriels, les
lobbyes, les voilà, c'est ces gens-là
dans leur caresse. C'est pas les
hackurs, c'est pas les c'est
exceptionnel, mais c'est pas c'est pas
voilà, c'est pas les gens qui vivent le
truc au quotidien, c'est ceux qui font
du business avec. Donc du coup forcément
ils orientent, ils donnent leur voilà,
ils font marcher le truc dans leur
intérêt. Donc forcément je les livres
enseigner à l'école ou ce genre de
choses, c'est peut-être des instites
mais ça sera pas une volonté euh
politique. En tout cas euh pas je
reviens sur je reviens sur
Jérémie pour pour pouvoir faire germer
cette volonté.
Euh est-ce que tu penses qu'il faudrait
un élément exotique pour les fédérer ?
Est-ce que tu tu penses qu'il faudrait
un parce que c'est c'est quand même
c'est t'entendre dire ces
préconisations, c'est très facile à
mettre en place et moi au niveau de la
sémiologie, je me pose la question
pourquoi c'est pas mis en place ? Alors
bon, le problème c'est que je viens de
passer 7 ans à temps plein à courir dans
les couloirs euh des parlements, des
ministères, du Parlement européen, de la
Commission européenne et cetera et que
j'en sors avec la très forte impression
qu'il va falloir aller faire ces
choses-là ailleurs. Euh et en même temps
la conviction qu'il faut pas abandonner
ces terrainslà. Euh je vais pas parler
en terme aussi cru que la corruption du
processus politique et pourtant j'ai du
mal à trouver d'autres mots. Euh oui,
une somme d'incompétences, de corruption
plus ou moins douce euh de manque de
courage politique, de de de déconnexion
avec la la réalité aussi fait qu'il est
extrêmement difficile de faire avancer
ces choses-là. Donc, qu'est-ce qui
pourra impulser ce genre de dynamique ?
C'est très dur comme question. peut-être
peut-être un renouvellement
générationnel de la classe politique,
mais je suis pas sûr qu'on ait le temps
d'attendre ça. Je suis pas sûr que ces
outils de contrôle social vont même
permettre un renouvellement de la classe
politique. Et un des objectifs de tout
ça, c'est peut-être aussi de de rester
au pouvoir pour ceux qui y sont. Un
autre élément euh peut-être, c'est un
exemple qui vient d'ailleurs. Euh j'ai
j'ai pas suivi les dernières étapes d'un
test texte qui devait être adopté par le
CAC qui est le rassemblement de tous les
pays d'Amérique moins les USA et le
Canada. Donc tous les pays d'Amérique
centrale latine et des Caraïbes qui
disent "Internet est un bien commun, la
surveillance de masse est inacceptable.
Euh et euh si des politiques publiques
se mettent en œuvre euh au Brésil et
ailleurs euh commencent à générer et euh
un momentum politique et un momentum
économique en bon suiviste peut-être que
les politiques publiques européennes s'y
mettront. Et un autre que j'aimerais
vraiment que l'on évite, un autre
paramètre qui pourrait faire changer les
choses, c'est une catastrophe. Euh comme
on apprend à faire des backup le jour où
on perd un disque
dur, comme on apprend le chiffrement le
jour où on se retrouve avec toutes ces
données exposé sur sur la place
publique. Euh j'aimerais pas qu'on en
vienne à prendre le logiciel libre le
jour où on sera fait paralyser nos nos
systèmes par des alliés de l'OTAN ou par
des gens qui auraient pris le contrôle
d'une partie du système de l'OTAN et
vous sera démontré par A+ B que notre
faiblesse aura été de dépendre
d'entreprise US pour notre nos les
aspects stratégiques de notre notre
information.
J'espère Triston.
Alors moi, j'ai j'ai un petit espoir
dans le marché et dans les gens qui font
du logiciel
libre. Comme Corben, j'essaie de
regarder là où on peut là où les choses
peuvent marcher et
puis d'y mettre mon énergie. Donc ça
commence par l'éducation. C'est pour ça
que je fais ce livre en essayant de le
rendre aussi facile d'abord que
possible. Euh et puis il y a aussi des
gens qui font du logiciel libre en
France et euh il est pas exclu que il y
en ait qui fasse du logiciel libre qui
soit utilisable par tous hein. On a
réussi à le faire à l'époque où j'étais
chez Mozilla. On l'a fait avec Firefox.
c'estd qu'on a fait un logiciel qui est
libre mais qui est facile à utiliser et
450 millions de personnes l'ont
téléchargé et installé sur leur machine
et on a réussi à remettre le web le web
d'Applom. Euh maintenant la
problématique Jérémy si tu as enchaîné
enchaîne. Web il est il est pas autant
aussi droit que je je le je le
souhaiterais. il est depuis c'est
étonnamment concentré, centralisé en
silo, euh ce qui est finalement le
problème qu'on est en train de décrire
actuellement. Euh mais euh il va falloir
euh euh trouver de l'énergie pour faire
euh des logiciels libres au service des
utilisateurs qui répondent à toute la
problématique dont on vient de discuter.
Mais et là c'est là où je suis pas
d'accord avec Corben, c'est que bon
d'accord aujourd'hui on le voit par
chiffre ses mail mais c'est un cauchemar
quoi. dur, je le fais enfin ça fait 4è
fois que je m'y remets depuis 2005 à à
même 80 en 99 j'avais déjà recommencé à
chiffrer et c'est vraiment compliqué et
c'est moche et on perd des
fonctionnalités et cetera mais il faut
pas se résoudre à ça. Le système il
marchera vraiment où on fera des
logiciels libres et des solutions libres
qui feront meilleur que Google et c'est
possible parce que justement c'est pas
Google. On peut faire ça avec des
acteurs qui ne se qui se méfient de
Google mais qui seraient d'accord pour
partir par exemple dans une logique de
d'autohébergement ou bien le chiffrement
ou le logiciel combiné ensemble euh
pourrait être au service de
l'utilisateur. Donc il faut faire mieux
et c'est possible. C'est ce que je dis
c'est dans l'état actuel des choses, on
est obligé de perdre du confort et mon
espoir c'est comme ce que tu dis c'est
que on puisse faire mieux et et le jour
on fera mieux les gens vont se
précipiter dessus parce que ça fait
mieux et en plus c'est respectueux. euh
de ton intimité numérique. Actuellement,
il y a rien il y a rien de parfait. Mais
effectivement, tu disais Firefox, c'est
une c'est un bon exemple de de ça. S'il
y a pas Firefox là maintenant, on serait
quoi ? Chrome, Internet Explorer, Lynx
ou pas de web du tout ? Non mais parle
pas de parle pas de Lynx. Euh voilà
mais ça serait triste quoi. Enfin dire
déjà il y a un projet qu'on a pas
mentionné qui en est au stade
embryonnaire et dans lequel j'ai j'ai
euh j'ai espoir qui s'appelle Caliopen.
Caliopen, c'est Laurent Chemla qui
initie ça. Ça aurait pas été Laurent
Chemla, j'aurais jamais cru. Si croire
et c'est un projet qui projette d'un
mailbox autour de tous les protocoles de
communication pour permettre d'aller
plus facilement possible vers le
chiffrement. Là c'est quelque chose. Si
tes amis financiers cherchent à investir
dans quelque chose qui fera le
rayonnement français machin machin
Caliopen les gars. Ça c'est du bon.
Quand quand tu vois quand tu vois
Cameron dire qu'il est contre le
chiffreement et qu'il veut interdire le
chiffre. Attends attends. Alors avant ce
gros morceau là parce que je suis
d'accord avec ce que ce que disent
Tristan et Manu mais il faut faire mieux
en terme de de fonctionnalité tout ce
qu'on veut. Maintenant, il faut aussi
faire vachement mieux en terme de
comment on développe le logiciel libre
lui-même. Parce que tu disais Firefox,
ça a rendu le logiciel libre accessible.
C'est vrai, euh ça a rendu, je sais plus
les termes que tu as utilisé, on a on a
réparé le le web. Euh c'est faux. Euh
déjà, outre le choix politique de
Mozilla d'accepter les DRM dans HTML 5
qui a été un coup de poignard dans le
dos du logiciel libre et la seule
justification, comment on appelle ça ?
Un coup de pupute, non ? Écoute, le le
seul la seule justification qu'on a
entendu de cette entreprise qui jusqu'à
présent disait "Regardez, on est les
copains de l'internet libre, on est le
libre, on est le libre." C'était oui
mais vous comprenez, sinon on va perdre
des perdre des parts de marché. Ça a été
le seul argument pour justifier qu'on
mette un instrument de contrôle au cœur
d'un logiciel comme Firefox. Mais je je
c'est pas là-dessus même que je veux
troller. Là où je veux troller, c'est
que Firefox déjà, je pense que le web
est perdu.
Le web est perdu parce que la moindre
page web qu'on regarde fait appel à des
à des logiciels de JavaScript qui va
s'excuter dans ton navigateur qui vient
de 10 ou 15 provenances différentes
qu'avec les CDN et les trucs et les
machins, c'est mettre son doigt dans un
dans un trou sans pas compliqué, on a
dit aujourd'hui. D'accord, fait ça.
Voilà. Donc déjà, je pense qu'on on a
perdu le web comme technologie dans
laquelle on pourrait un jour avoir
confiance parce que un interpréteur
JavaScript dans un machin comme un
navigateur web, je sais pas combien de
millions de lignes de code il y a dans
Firefox, 100 millions. C'est énorme.
Oui, c'est c'est un truc, c'est ça doit
être 10 fois plus de lignes de code
qu'il y en a dans une fusée ou dans dans
un dans un des machins les plus
complexes que que que l'on que l'on
maîtrise. Mais le problème c'est que
dans une fusée, chaque ligne de code qui
est écrite est auditée par 10 personnes
derrière est audité 10 fois. Et nous on
sait écrire du code, c'est facile, c'est
rigolo. Un machin comme Firefox, il y a
plein de bénévoles pas payés machin qui
vont contribuer des liges et des lignes
et des lignes, mais la capacité à tester
chaque nouvelle ligne avec tout et à
tout tester, je crois qu'il reste encore
aujourd'hui dans Firefox des lignes de
code qui datent de Netscape, c'estàdire
qui ont été foutu là il y a 10 ou 15 ou
20 ans. Il nous faudrait dépenser à vue
de nez et je suis pas un financier mais
à vue de nez entre une et 10 fois plus
de ressources qu'on en investit dans
l'écriture du code, dans l'audit du
code. Dans l'audit et dans le pen test
non ? Dans le Oui, le test en général.
Et ça c'est un truc qu'on ne sait pas
faire, qu'on a pas théorisé, qu'on
laisse pudiquement à d'autres et on l'a
vu cette année, il y a des trous de
sécurité majeur dans Open SSL qui qui
ont déstabilisé les 3/4 des serveurs web
de la planète. Hard Bed là, c'est ça
Hardble Bleed et peut-être 100 % des
serveurs des entreprises du Fortune 500
parce que c'est un bout de logiciel qui
venait d'une entité qui avait je crois
4000 dollars par mois de budget le mois
où on a découvert ça. Tout le Fortune
500 et 4000 dollars de budget.
remplir remplir les pointilles. Je tiens
juste à dire que chez Mozilla le code il
est relu au moins deux fois par donc
écrit une fois, relu une première fois
et ensuite s'il est validé, il est relu
par une troisème personne et il y a
forcément des tests qui sont faits. Et
vous êtes vous y êtes mis à combien pour
mettre des DRM ? Vous étiez Ah non mais
ce que ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
reprocher euh il y a une discussion
enfin je veux dire vraiment on a on a
tous détesté on a mis les DRM en
vomissant hein c'estd que pour nous
c'est une décision qui nous c'était
vraiment en ce qui motivé c'est ce qui a
motivé ton départ de Mozill non non non
c'était pas c'était pas enfin c'était
extrêmement déplaisant de de faire ça
parce que enfin moi je suis farouchement
opposé au DRM maintenant on a eu des
débats en interne et il a fallu trancher
et c'était la moins pire des solutions
entre ça et faire mourir Mozilla. Euh
c'était pour nous c'était clair parce
que à partir du moment où tu commences à
dire "Ah, je me refuse à mettre des DRM
et puis que Netflix qui aux États-Unis a
un succès énorme et ben si tu veux pas
lire Netflix dans Firefox en quelques
mois tu perds tu perds toute ton
audience et tu sers plus à rien." Non.
Oui mais mais après tu as plus d'impact.
C'est pas un problème de marché, c'est
un problème d'impact sur le monde. Si tu
as trois utilisateurs, tu finis comme
opéra et tu changes pas le monde.
Tristant, tristant. Euh et dire par
exemple, c'est on est dans dans un
scénario de de science-fiction, mais
dire voilà Modzila, on arrête parce que
on veut plus. Pour nous, le net c'est
plus ça, ça c'est un impact. Non non,
mais même politiquement dire nous on
sera on restera le navigateur
indépendant, le navigateur rebelle.
jamais machin
nous chons de sujet mais là il y a
problème c'est un choix politique c'est
un choix politique justifié par des
termes économiques de part de marché
mais c'est un vrai choix politique et a
fait le choix politique qui était celui
des parts de marché celui d'avoir de
l'impact dans le futur c'est soit tu
survis et tu as des pars de marché et
donc tu impactes le mond tes utilisateur
non non parce que la façon dont on l'a
fait euh Le le le Oui oui je vais
discuter tout seul avec Corb. Moi c'est
là c'est là où c'est il y a les les
limites. Enfin tu vois par exemple tu
parlais de d'open SSL avec sa faille
parce que il y a un Gus qui fait
n'importe quoi et parce que ils ont 4000
€ de budget par an ou je sais pas quoi.
Mais le financement du GIP c'est un vrai
problème et et il y a personne qui
finance ça et OK c'est bien d'être tout
blanc et de s'accrocher à des à ses
valeurs et cetera, mais il y a des
moments effectivement comme ce qu'a fait
Mozilla avec Google ou avec le DRM. tu
es obligé si tu veux tu te mars mais
c'est vrai enfin moi c'est je vais
peut-être me faire mais tu es obligé de
de faire un pas de côté pour continuer à
avancer dans la bonne direction sinon tu
crèves et puis c'est la la c'est le
chemin qui s d'accord on refera une
émission là-dessus si vous voulez je
vais dernière question une chacun un
conseil aux jeunes génération c'est
classique à chaque fois que vous passez
dans l'émission c'est c'est la question
fatal c'est un conseil aux jeunes
génération une bouteille à la mer sur
Internet. On va commencer par Corben.
Ouais. Ben moi si j'ai un truc à dire,
c'est prenez pas tout comme enfin toutes
les infos comme elles viennent.
Documentez-vous, essayez des trucs.
Voilà,
réfléchissez et puis mettez-les un peu
les mains dans le cambouille. C'est pas
c'est pas si compliqué que ça quoi.
Enfin, faut essayer de Ouais. de se
poser les bonnes questions, de creuser,
quoi. Faut creuser. Tristan, bah ça va
un peu dans le même sens. J'irai pas
jusqu'à dire qu'il faut lire mon bouquin
qu'il est pas encore sorti. Mais c'est
c'est ça. Moi, je veux donner la la les
billes aux gens pour essayer de
comprendre l'internet et commencer à
agir. Neut pas tomber euh dans la
résignation. C'est ça la difficulté
aujourd'hui dans dans toute la
surveillance et et ce il y a il y a
cette impression d'impuissance. Les
entreprises vous disent que avec Apple
c'est magique et donc on est passif ou
bien sinon c'est l'horreur. Non, il y a
possibilité de faire des choses. Il faut
creuser. La l'informatique c'est
passionnant. Enfin, je pense qu'on en
est tous convaincu autour de cette
table. Et donc il faut prendre son
destin en main, commencer à
bidouiller, regarder ce qu'on peut faire
avec des logiciels libres et c'est
excitant. et on se sent empowered, on
sent qu'on reprend le pouvoir et euh
c'est fun et en plus ça nous sert pour
l'avenir. Jérémy, ben moi j'ai
l'impression de dire un petit peu la
même chose euh à savoir questionner tout
se question demander des réponses ou
question. Non non questionner par
exemple se questionner soi-même quand on
à chaque fois qu'on fait un choix le
remettre en question poser la question à
des autres prendre d'autres avis quand
on lit quelque chose le questionner
c'est-à-dire croiser ses sources et
aussi l'autorité et ne ne jamais rien
prendre pour argent comptant toujours
vérifier les choses avant de se faire sa
propre opinion c'est Aaron Schwarz qui
disait lisez posez-vous les questions et
que une une grande partie de ce que l'on
appelle l'intelligence est en fait de la
curiosité et cette curi curiosité, je
pense que c'est ce qu'il y a au cœur de
la démarche à cœur de de cette cet
enthousiasme vis-à-vis de la technologie
qui pousse à toujours vouloir contrôler
la technologie plutôt qu'à contrôlé par
elle. Je pense que c'est un un des
enjeux de société les plus importants
pour le le futur de nos de nos de notre
humanité et que ce qui a été corrompu
là, c'est notre rapport à la
technologie. On s'est fait chiper, on
s'est fait voler, on s'est fait voler le
contrôle de nos de nos machines qu'il
s'agit de le reprendre. Et pour le
reprendre, il faut se poser la question
de ce rapport à la technologie, se poser
la question de comment fonctionne la
technologie et se poser la question de
comment à titre individuel et à titre
collectif, on va on va changer tout ça.
Messieur, merci. Merci.